Afra Muhammad her daughters and her
grandchildren have lived in this
classroom for six months the school in
Harum has become a temporary shelter for
some of the many Sudanese forced from
their homes by the conflict between the
Army and the paramilitary rapid support
forces Afra says they fled when the
fighting moved into their
neighborhood it was terrible to leave
the house we carried the kids left the
air conditioning on and left with
nothing but the clothes on our backs
artillery shells landed near us stray
bullets were flying
everywhere early in the conflict the
paramilitary group took control of most
of the capital amid reported theft rape
and killing many residents moved to
safer regions often areas controlled by
the Army in darur where the rapid
support forces is accused of ethnic
cleansing half a million escaped to
neighboring Chad another million have
crossed the border into South Sudan
Egypt and Ethiopia bringing the total
number of displaced Sudanese to nearly
11 million according to United Nations
figures families often travel long
distances by foot to reach
safety there are families that walked
for 3 days to get here they hadn't eaten
and were in poor health one woman
collapsed during the journey and died
people ared physically and emotionally
exhausted with no official displacement
camps and the shortage of tents many
people sleep out in the open access to
food clean water and Health Care is also
difficult back in Kum Afra says
conditions are far from ideal but at
least her family is safe for now anyway
there is no sign the conflict is going
to end anytime soon meaning more
Sudanese will likely be forced from
their homes hiam Moran Al jaaz
Harum make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer